Okay, so we've got our door opening and closing, it's lerping open nicely, we've got some inputs
going on, we've got some more complicated functionality happening and overall we're
in a really good place. Now if we just left it there that would be job done, we've
got a door opening and closing. But let's take it one step further, let's try and
lock the door and create a button that then opens this door. First thing we want
to do is we actually want to figure out a way to lock the door. And the easiest
way to lock a door is by creating a bool. I'm going to call this bool is locked
is locked, there we go. I'm going to create a lowercase is and a capital L.
Now a capitalized letter in a variable will create a space between the
previous letter and the capital letter. So let's just call that is locked. By
default when you create a new variable it will be a bool. If we need to
create a different type of variable, we've got a whole list of variables
here which I'll dig into at the end of this class. By default we would just
want a boolean anyway. So is locked is fine. The only thing I want to do
here, again for in the aid of good naming convention, organization, when you
select the bool in the details panel, the category here, I'm going to call it
door properties. So again capital D, capital P, I'm going to call it door
properties in the category. And it creates a category down here, it makes
things nice and organized and it just keeps things separate for where we need
them. So I'm going to compile, save and then what I'm going to do is on the
interact I'm going to drag that to the side. I'm going to drag out by a
left mouse dragging on the is locked, same way we dragged the door out before and
when you let go you'll see two options, get and set. So we either get the
variable or set the variable. For now we're going to get the variable and
we'll go into set variable in a second. So we want to get the variable. Now a
quick way, again we love a good shortcut key on the keyboard, if you hold down
control and left mouse drag it will automatically get a variable. If you hold
down alt it will automatically grab a set variable. So control for get, alt for
set, again we don't need those at the moment so we'll just delete them but
good shortcut keys to keep in mind. On the is locked I'm going to drag out
of the the bool, I'm going to create a branch. I'm going to hit enter on the
branch. Again another shortcut is B so you could hold down B on the keyboard
and left click to create a branch but I'm going to create a branch. Pressed is
locked true, you want it to be false sorry. So is it locked true? Don't do
anything. Is locked false? Well if it's not locked then you can open the door.
Now again just for quick debugging we want that we could drag out of here and
even though this will turn into a bit of spaghetti it's okay for the purposes now
because we're just going to print the string. But on true I've just created a
print string and you could say in capital letters door locked three
exclamation marks just to punctuate that. So I'm going to compile, save. The
only last thing I want to do is on door locked I want to set this to true.
So I'm going to set this to true and I'm going to compile and save. I'm going to go
into my map I'm going to go over to the door I'm going to press E and it'll
say door locked on the top left there so every time I try to open it no
matter what I try door is locked. So cool we've got the functionality there
we've got door locked. I'm going to remove this print string for now and
yeah so we've got a door lock functionality and I want to show you
how to make those an editable property now in the next video.